ahora que ya conocemos la magnitud de la
aceleración debida a la gravedad a 400
kilómetros sobre la superficie terrestre
donde donde pensábamos o donde suponemos
que la estación espacial puede estar
deambulando verdad ahora ya que sabemos
eso lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar qué tan rápido tiene que ir esta
estación espacial para ir evadiendo a la
tierra mientras caes ok entonces
mientras va dando vueltas alrededor de
la tierra mientras va cayendo lo que
necesitamos es ver cuál es la velocidad
necesaria que debe llevar para estar
siempre esquivando la o con lo que es lo
mismo es para que conserve su movimiento
circular
es decir que que se mantenga en órbita
verdad y lo que ya sabemos de lo que
hemos estado estudiando sobre movimiento
circular es que si suponemos que esta
estación tiene velocidad constante
entonces lo que sí podemos garantizar es
que hay cierto tipo de aceleración
centrípeta verdad y que de hecho esa
aceleración centrípeta no es otra cosa
más que la
aceleración debida a la gravedad muy
bien entonces teniendo eso en mente uno
puede simplemente acordarse que la
aceleración centrípeta se calcula como
la velocidad al cuadrado entre el radio
donde la velocidad quiere decir la
velocidad que debe llevar este objeto
que es la estación espacial y r es el
radio del movimiento aquí estamos
suponiendo que es del centro de la
tierra hasta la trayectoria de nuestra
estación espacial que de hecho ya lo
habíamos calculado aquí es de seis mil
771 kilómetros o que lo podemos ver en
notación científica como de 6.700 71 por
10 a las 6 metros y es muy importante
mantener bien las unidades en metros y
segundos muy bien entonces nosotros
queremos saber cuál es la velocidad así
que podemos multiplicar de ambos lados
por r y tendremos que la velocidad al
cuadrado es la aceleración centrípeta
por
r pero nosotros queremos velocidad así
que lo único que basta hacer es sacar
una raíz cuadrada de ambos lados y
tendremos que la velocidad es la
aceleración centrípeta por el radio y
sacamos raíz cuadrada de eso muy bien
entonces ya tenemos todo lo necesario
para calcular la velocidad simplemente
sacamos la calculadora y hacemos la
multiplicación tenemos 8.69 de la
aceleración y ahora hay que multiplicar
por el radio que son 6.771 y ahorita
vemos qué pasa con con las potencias de
10 esto nos da 58.83 999 ok pero hay que
sacar raíz cuadrada y eso nos da 7.670
ok 7.67 vamos a dejarlo ahí ok ahora si
sacamos raíz cuadrada de 10 a la 6
eso es 10 a la 3 verdad o lo que es lo
mismo multiplicar por mil
así que si multiplicamos eso por 1000
siete mil seiscientos setenta casi
podríamos decir siete mil 671 pero vamos
a dejarlo solo como 7.670 muy bien
entonces tenemos que la velocidad a la
que debe ir la estación espacial es de
siete mil seiscientos setenta metros por
segundo
ok y nada más para que te des una idea
de que estamos diciendo con esto vamos a
tratar de contextualizar lo de otra
forma en realidad estamos diciendo que
esta estación espacial debe viajar cada
segundo cada segundo debe viajar siete
mil seiscientos setenta metros o casi
podríamos verlo como que debe moverse
siete kilómetros por segundo te imaginas
la velocidad que debe llevar este esta
estación es muchísimo es bastante son
siete kilómetros cada segundo
aproximadamente de hecho podríamos hacer
la conversión para ver cómo expresar lo
en kilómetros por hora por ejemplo que
es la velocidad en la que
se manejan los carros si nosotros
tenemos esta velocidad siete mil
seiscientos setenta metros sobre segundo
multiplicamos por por esto que son tres
mil seiscientos segundos hay en cada
hora verdad esto es como haber hecho una
multiplicación por uno verdad tres mil
seiscientos segundos es lo mismo que una
hora así que esto es multiplicar por uno
y ahora si queremos convertir metros a
kilómetros sólo hay que acordarnos que
en un kilómetro en un kilómetro hay mil
metros verdad y dónde ponemos las
unidades pues por ejemplo queremos
cancelar metros hay que ponerlo abajo y
el kilómetro abajo y hacer este este
tipo de conversiones que ya hay
muchísimos vídeos aquí en kant academy
al respecto entonces qué es lo que
tendríamos que hacer
tendríamos que multiplicar este número
que habíamos obtenido por 3600 y luego
dividir entre mil aunque entonces
estamos dice
que este objeto se mueve 227 mil 614 27
mil 614 kilómetros cada hora eso es
muchísimo es muchísimo ok entonces de
hecho ni siquiera podemos encontrar
avión alguno o algún gesto o cualquier
objeto que se mueva tan rápido en la
tierra de hecho por ejemplo si tenemos
un avión aquí
aunque digamos este avión
algo así si si tenemos un avión
moviéndose a super super super velocidad
como es que no podemos alcanzar una
velocidad como la de la estación
espacial y eso se explica fácilmente
porque aquí en la tierra hay muchísimo
aire hay muchísimo aire todo está
cubierto de aire entonces lo que ocurre
es que este avión o más bien tiene una
resistencia debido al aire verdad las
partículas empiezan a chocar aquí a
medida que este avión se va trasladando
verdad y todo el aire comienza a chocar
con el avión de tal suerte que empieza a
desacelerar la verdad no le permite
tener una velocidad tan alta en cambio
con la estación espacial ésta se
encuentra en el digamos fuera a una a
una distancia razonable como para
suponer que el aire es casi cero es
decir es este este avión o este perdón
este esta estación espacial se encuentra
casi al vacío casi no hay aire o
partículas en el espacio exterior
entonces se encuentra casi al vacío ves
es despreciable la cantidad
de materia digamos que puede uno
encontrar a esas alturas muy bien ahora
lo que lo mantiene como ya habíamos
dicho en movimiento circular es justo la
gravedad eso es porque está esquivando
la tierra cada vez que intenta caer
entonces si llevamos a esta velocidad de
7.670 nos podremos mantener en órbita
pero qué pasaría si por ejemplo si no
hubiera gravedad este cuerpo en por por
las leyes de newton se mantendría en
movimiento
este recto verdad que literalmente se
saldría por la tangente como si ahí sí
hay aceleración por ejemplo si si
tuviéramos un poco menos de esta
velocidad quiere decir entonces que
mientras vamos dando vueltas a lo mejor
va espiral de 'no va haciendo espirales
hacia el centro de la tierra si por el
contrario tuviéramos una velocidad mucho
más grande entonces empezaríamos a
movernos hacia afuera de la tierra en
espiral muy bien entonces esta velocidad
es
para mantenernos en órbita y por
supuesto que la estación espacial debe
tener algunas herramientas o algunas
bajo la manga para que si empieza a
variar esta velocidad pueda al menos que
pueda al menos regresar a su trayectoria
original